I don't know which one I want to eat
first cuz they look so good
eeny meeny miny moe yes it worked you
know when you're a kid and you used to
fit you used to know how to like
manipulate that so that you would land
on what what you actually wanted hey
guys I'm a beach art welcome to Abby's
kitchen so as you know I am on the home
stretch of this pregnancy and when I get
up in the morning I need to eat a SAP
and like so many of you guys I find it
pretty much impossible to get vegetables
in the morning so I've discovered a
really tasty way to do it and I'm gonna
share my recipe for notes three ways so
zoats
is kind of like the fun pet name for
zucchini oats and I've already shown you
how to bust out the pros so now I'm just
basically working my way through the
alphabet with my oatmeal but this is a
really great recipe because it's
delicious it's really satisfying and
it's vegetable packed let's do this
first up my peanut butter and bananas
oats to a saucepot I add some
unsweetened vanilla almond milk some
rolled oats cocoa pattern
rape banana cinnamon and a pinch of salt
and I let that simmer over medium heat
until it gets nice and thick then I stir
in some natural peanut butter some
vanilla some dried banana chips and of
course our zucchini then I give that a
good little stir then off the heat I add
some crushed peanuts and some vegan
chocolate chips stir it up and let's get
plating to my bowl I add another scoop
of peanut butter some fresh bananas some
decent chocolate chips and some crushed
peanuts enjoy next my chocolate and
raspberries oats
[Music]
to sauce pot I add some unsweetened
vanilla almond milk rolled oats cocoa
powder ripe banana frozen raspberries
cinnamon and a pinch of salt and I'll
let that simmer over medium heat until
it gets nice and thick then I add some
unsweetened almond butter some almonds
and some vanilla as well as our zucchini
and then I give that a good stir to
serve I add a scoop of almond butter
some fresh raspberries
lots of almonds and of course some vegan
chocolate chip enjoy
[Music]
finally my apple and cinnamon zoats
to my sauce pot I add some unsweetened
vanilla almond milk world oats grape
banana cinnamon nutmeg a pinch of salt
and some diced Apple and they give that
a good stir over medium heat until it
all thickens up nicely then I add in a
scoop of cashew butter raisins zucchini
and some vanilla and I give it another
stir until it all thickens up to serve I
top it off with some cashew butter some
sliced apples golden raisins a pinch of
cinnamon and some ham parts enjoy mmm
even meenie miney moe catch a tiger by
the toe if he hollers let him go eeny
meeny miny moe peanut butter a banana
and chocolate always win so I'm going in
for the kill
so yummy hmm who does not love banana
chocolate and peanut butter well guys I
hope you enjoyed these recipes for my
gluten free vegan zoats three ways an
easy amazing way to get some vegetables
in your morning if you did be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with some of your favorite add-ins
and toppings for your oatmeal subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]